[Musique]
vous avez dit un jour le danger pour
l'écrivain noir c'est qu'il s'enferme
dans sa noirceur qu'est-ce que vous
vouliez dire par là je pense que le
principe même de l'écriture c'est de ne
pas se recoqueviller c'est de ne pas
rester à l'intérieur de la case de son
père quand on écrit un livre on ouvre
des portes on ouvre des fenêtres et moi
je pense que en tant qu'écrivain
africain noir congolais je n'ai pas
m'enfermé dans ce que les autres
attendent de moi c'est-à-dire que je
sois celui qui 24 heures sur 24 parle de
ma condition de noir pourtant si on
regarde votre oeuvre qui est abondante
avec comme dernier livre le commerce des
allongés qui est sorti à la fin du mois
d'août dernier
on est toujours grosso modo on est en
Afrique et on est souvent au Congo
Brazzaville qui est votre pays que ça
vous inspire quand même beaucoup oui ça
c'est ça inspire ça c'est l'imaginaire
ça c'est l'ensemble de ce qui tisse une
œuvre la géographie n'est pas en soi la
chose la plus dangereuse en littérature
ce qui est dangereux c'est le fait de
plaquer des éléments qui sont sans
multiples constitutifs des individus
d'accord moi je peux être au Congo et
une fenêtre ouverte vers le monde après
tout quand on lit les textes des grands
écrivains quels qu'ils soient ils sont
toujours les relayeurs de leurs
géographie il parle depuis leur
territoire il parle de la Russie comme
Tolstoï il parle de la Colombie comme
Gabriel Garcia Marquez il parle de
l'Algérie je ne sais pas comme Boualem
sans sale mais en même temps le discours
qu'ils ont une dimension universelle
parce que l'universalité c'est d'abord
le local mais avec des sans les murs qui
sont et alors vous vous êtes citoyen du
monde pour le coup c'est le cas vous
êtes
congolais mais vous enseignez aux
États-Unis vous venez très souvent en
France et votre inspiration vous la
puisez de toutes ces de tous ces voyages
de toutes ces expériences et vous
mélangez tout ça je pense aussi que le
voyage est quelque chose d'essentiel
quand vous êtes voyageur vous empruntez
la discipline du caméléon d'accord vous
prenez la couleur de l'environnement qui
vous entoure vous avez ce que je
rappelle souvent aussi dans mes livres
et que j'ai puisé du côté de Amadou
empatheba c'est-à-dire l'attitude du
caméléon grand écrivain il va tout droit
et quand il veut regarder à gauche sa
tête reste droite il regarde seulement
par les yeux alors vous avez été honneur
suprême très belle honneur professeur au
Collège de France en 2016 et vous avez
prononcé à cette occasion une leçon
inaugurale qui est une leçon absolument
magistral c'est le cas de le dire qui
s'appelle lettre noire des ténèbres à la
lumière et dans cette exposé qui est
assez long vous avez pas là-dedans trait
tendre pour vos aînés écrivains
africains vous les critiquez en disant
que ils ont pas pris leur ils se sont
pas émancipés comme il aurait fallu je
pense c'est un constat global il ne sais
pas simplement des blâmer les aînés mais
de blâmer une certaine
pensée de cette époque là où il y avait
la pensée coloniale bien sûr la pensée
coloniale il y avait la pensée des
expéditions la partie des découvertes la
pensée
occidentale qui essayait de percer l'âme
du continent africain et beaucoup
d'auteurs ont embrassé cette sorte de
littérature on s'en faire du bien au
continent africain mais ils étaient là
en train de légitimer en quelque sorte
la feuille de route qui avait tracé les
expéditeurs les colons ce qui avait les
préjugés faciles pour nous décrire
est-ce que vous avez déjà lu le roman
d'un spahi de Pierre Loti bien sûr je
pense quelque chose c'est quelque chose
ça fait partie vous savez c'est
littérature qui sont des listeractions
d'exploration étaient là pour préparer
la littérature coloniale pleine de
préjugés on explore et on essaye de
donner un lecteur des éléments à
laissant qui vont lui dire je n'ai pas
peur d'aller à Bruce je veux pas être
mangé par le boa donc j'y vais quand les
Européens beaucoup d'Européens ne
voulaient pas aller dans les colonies il
leur fallait une propagande c'est pour
ça qu'on a eu les Tintin au Congo de
Hergé c'est pour ça qu'on a eu des
affiches c'est pour ça qu'on a eu des
publicités pour dire aux pauvres blancs
qui avaient peur d'aller en brousse on
dit c'est pas grave vous avez la belle
civilisation allez-y et donc il y en a
qui disent non il y en a qui disent oui
cette littérature d'exploration il y
avait toujours aussi des pépites quand
on a un bon écrivain quel que soit
peut-être l'ambiance générale insalubre
qui peut exister il y a toujours comme
ça est-ce que c'est une pépite pour vous
le premier Noir qui a eu le prix
Goncourt qui s'appelle René marrant qui
a écrit tout à la
en 1921 il a le prix Goncourt est-ce que
ce livre est un équerre paru d'ailleurs
assez récemment puisque c'est
l'anniversaire évidemment de cette alors
lui attention il est pas africain il est
Guy mais il a beaucoup vécu et il a été
d'ailleurs dans l'administration
coloniale notamment au Tchad qu'est-ce
que vous pensez de ce livre là c'est
bizarre parce que dans cette réédition
on écrit bateau Allah on dit seulement
roman c'est Albert Michel donc c'est
déjà une révision de notre époque lui
quand il avait publié son livre c'était
batwala véritable roman [__] c'était
ces mots et donc là vous voyez le titre
n'est plus là c'est une sorte de
révision ça c'est important de ma part
de ne pas respecter la volonté parce que
ces sous-titres là est important quand
il dit véritable roman [__] ça veut
dire qu'à l'époque où il publiait en
1921 c'était les Européens qui étaient
considérés comme les écrivains de
littérature africaine et lui il arrive
il dit non le véritable roman [__]
commence par moi batwala et quand vous
enlevez ça ça n'a plus de sens
historique alors [__] justement oui ça
renvoie à deux hommes illustrent qui
sont aimés césaires et et sonore Léopold
Sédar Senghor j'ajoute aussi quand même
Léon contrat Damas de la Guyane vous
avez complètement raison et sans gore
par exemple et ben vous en parlez
d'ailleurs dans votre leçon inaugurale
il a été très critiqué bon pour beaucoup
c'est un immense écrivain pour les
Européens c'est un immense écrivain un
grand poète mais critiquer aussi par la
jeune génération des écrivains parce que
justement un peu
un peu dans la compromission entre il y
a d'ailleurs il disait c'est il avait
cette phrase absolument incroyable il
louait la raison Hélène contre
l'intuition [__] est-il s'il y a
beaucoup d'Africains qui ont jamais
compris ça c'est je pense que c'était
les gens veulent pris la formule de
Senghor quand il disait que la raison
était laine comme l'émotionnel les
Occidentaux eux ils peuvent penser nous
on est que dans le rythme dans dans ce
sens là mais celui qui l'avait qui avait
bien peut-être expliqué ce que c'était
la négritude ce n'est pas un noir c'est
un blanc et il s'appelle Jean-Paul
Sartre il avait fait la préface de
l'anthologie de Senghor et cette préface
s'intitulaire orphénoire à l'intérieur
lui il disait que la négritude c'est
comme les noirs qui aiment maman plonge
vraiment très loin pour aller chercher
ce qui fait la substance de leur âme
leur âme c'est que le monde que nous
percevons chez nous n'est pas que
physique il est aussi ontologique il est
aussi au-delà de la réalité que nous
avons et pourquoi c'est un mot qu'on
emploie plus ou alors un mot quand on
l'emploi on est tout de suite qualifié
de raciste parce que les époques ont un
sens d'autodestruction linguistique on a
peur de l'histoire parce que l'histoire
pour certains rappelle des fêlures on a
peur d'avoir de dire le mot neuve un
blanc aurait du mal à dire j'ai croisé
un aigre mais les Américains quand ils
s'appellent ils se disent ils se disent
[__] mais entre eux mais ça n'a pas le
même sens parce que la société nous a
pris à en quelque sorte faire semblant
d'effacer quelque chose qui en réalité a
toujours existé moi je pense que le
racisme ne se combat pas en faisant
semblant dans lever les éléments du
vocabulaire mais en allant à la racine
en expliquant que ce mot même s'il est
mauvais que les transformer c'est pour
ça que négritude le monde négritude est
né il vient de [__] et les senghores
Césaire et Damas en ont fait une
esthétique africaine est-ce que vous
trouvez pas que là parce qu'on dit
souvent en Afrique ça continent
qui n'est pas rentré dans l'histoire on
dit ou un continent qui connaît moult
problème mais l'influence de l'Afrique
justement dans les arts elle n'a jamais
été aussi importante dans la musique
dans la littérature jamais ne serait-ce
qu'en Afrique francophone il y a eu
autant d'écrivains qui ont du succès
dans le monde entier d'ailleurs dans la
mode dans tous les arcs c'est quand même
quelque chose qui est pas suffisamment
noté ça c'est pas suffisamment noté et
je pense même que ça a été oublié à un
moment donné à l'époque de la négritude
la négritude n'a pas été créé que par
des noirs elle a été accompagnée aussi
par des Blancs
Michel Leir Théodore Monod Albert
Camille beaucoup allait du côté de la
rue des écoles à Paris à la librairie ou
maison d'édition présente africaine où
ils discutait me rendre revue aussi
voilà il sponsorisé la revue et à
l'époque même les Picasso et les autres
c'était rendu en Afrique avait vu les
arts qu'on appelait les arnègres et ça
en quelque sorte irrigué le mouvement de
symbolisme et de surréalisme pour eux il
y avait pas de doute que l'Afrique avait
ce côté mystérieux qui viendrait à
l'intérieur des arts et aujourd'hui on
le découvre petit à petit on voit
timidement dans la mode les grands
couturiers dont je ne citerai pas le nom
ici nous invite pour les défilés qu'ils
font
dans le continent africain parce qu'ils
ont compris que la mode elle est là et
que si les grandes vedettes comme les
Beyoncé les Jay-Z et autres comment ça
s'inspirer de la manière de s'habiller
en Afrique c'est qu'il y a une
esthétique que nous avons négligé depuis
longtemps et peut-être que c'est le
chéneau qui manque à notre humanité à
notre dialogue qu'on aurait en commun
alors vous parliez tout à l'heure on
parlait de la négritude on parlait de
des effets de d'époque
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de la culture
wok aujourd'hui qui est grandement
portée d'ailleurs par les
Afro-Américains oui et qui consiste à
remettre complètement en question
l'histoire ou le courant historique tel
qu'il existe à condamner des
personnalités du passé qui ont pu avoir
effectivement et des comportements que
évidemment aujourd'hui on n'accepterait
plus je pense que parfois
dans des sujets aussi délicats que
ceux-ci
il y a notre regard du présent qu'on
applique directement aux agissements du
passé il faut en quelque sorte aussi
s'assurer que si on veut rééquilibrer
les choses de manière dans l'histoire ou
quelque chose il faut d'abord maîtriser
ce qui a été dans l'histoire il faut
laisser toujours à côté du lieu du crime
les éléments qui permettront plus tard à
tout enquêteur de pouvoir revenir sur
l'enquête d'accord on ne peut pas
forcément par la poussée du temps ou
bien par le modernisme ou bien par la le
souffle très brutal des débats commencé
à tout équilibrer en pensant que nous
aujourd'hui nous sommes la civilisation
la plus achevée ou bien nous possédons
aujourd'hui le courant des pensées les
plus achevés parce que dans 50 ans
peut-être ce que nous pensons nous idéal
ne sera pas ne serait pas cela regardez
dans certaines
les jeunes du monde va falloir que les
modernismes ou les nouveaux débats les
entraîner très loin ils commencent à
réclamer l'ancien monde j'ai riais
beaucoup en regardant certaines vidéos
par exemple du Congo démocratique où les
enfants des grandes cérémonies pour
Mobutu alors que maman au moment RDC
Zaïre autrefois au moment où il mourait
tout le monde voulait s'en débarrasser
donc les changements même les plus
souhaités ont leur mélancolie parce que
le passé est lourd vous avez cette
phrase dans cette leçon que vous avez
prononcé au Collège de France se passer
ne passe toujours pas il habite notre
inconscient il gouverne parfois bien
malgré nous nos jugements et vit en nous
car il écrit nos destin dans le présence
c'est-à-dire que on est nécessairement
le produit de se passer là on est
nécessairement
habité vous quand vous écrivez vous êtes
habité parce
oui on est non seulement on est habité
par ce passé mais le peu de temps qu'on
peut se permettre de le mettre à côté il
y a toujours l'autre qui viendra vous
rappeler cela nous sommes en tant que
africain des corps qui se déplacent avec
le poids de l'histoire c'est peut-être
c'est là aussi le paradoxe moi j'ai fait
des études en France où je me retrouvais
dans une classe on était 17 en troisième
cycle de doctorat il y avait 16 blondes
j'étais le seul noir mais dans la foulée
il m'arrivait d'oublier finalement
qu'ils étaient c'est quand les autres
mais regardez que je veux dire en effet
je suis comme une mousse dans une
casserole de lait donc ça se voit d'être
loin vous dites j'adore cette formule je
peux vous la vie dites la France est
toujours en sourdine c'est toujours cela
moi je pense que il y a il y a la lutte
demain de la même manière
lutte contre les préjugés il faut lutter
contre l'hypocrisie de cette histoire ou
dans dans la mesure où
pour que on puisse reconnaître ce que je
fais je dois le faire deux fois plus que
l'occidental ah oui parce que si je le
fais comme l'occidental à quoi bon je
pars de démembrer puisque l'occidental
est là c'est lui qui le fera et si je le
fais deux fois que l'occidental n'arrive
pas à le faire là avec secret un élément
peut-être de dépendance même de
l'Occident vis-à-vis de ce que je suis
en train de faire on nous a toujours
peut-être mis dans une situation où il
ne faut surtout pas être le dernier de
la classe puisqu'on vous a mis déjà dans
le dernier de l'histoire et vous avez
une autre formule qui est absolument
extraordinaire vous avez dit que la
colonisation française elle avait
quelque chose d'affectif ce qui n'est
pas le cas de la colonisation
britannique par exemple oui parce que
les anglophones dès qu'ils avaient senti
que leur commençait à crepiter ils ont
rangé les affaires ils sont partis parce
qu'ils étaient là pour faire les
appartements partout au Kenya ça a été
violent
mais grosso modo grosso modo quand on
voit comment la France accrochait à
l'Algérie la France elle s'est livré à
des référendum voilà donc la France non
seulement voulait avoir l'aspect
économique de la colonisation mais
administrative coloniale culturelle etc
c'est vraiment ce sont je suis le père
de la nation en quelque sorte donc c'est
pour ça que j'ai toujours qualifié la
colonisation française qui était de
l'ordre à la fois aussi de l'affection
dans le sens où la France voulait
s'assurer que il avait enlevé dans le
cerveau de son colonisé tout ce qui
avait très à sa propre culture et avait
mis à l'intérieur les éléments de la
culture qu'elle pensait être celle de la
civilisation alors Barack Obama l'ancien
président américain a dit un jour
l'Afrique n'a pas besoin d'hommes forts
elle a besoin d'institutions solides
vous êtes d'accord avec ça oui je pense
que les hommes prétendument fort nous
ont entraîné dans les désastre qui est
aujourd'hui puisque homme fort en
Afrique ça veut dire dictateur ça devait
pas dire malgré tout ça veut dire
quelqu'un qui s'accroche au pouvoir qui
change les institutions et ou alors
avant de partir qui met ses enfants et
donc quand Barack Obama parle
d'institution il parle tout simplement
du fait que nous devons avoir un
renouvellement démocratique par le jeu
des de la Constitution par le jeu des
lois nous devons respecter l'alternance
nous devons respecter l'opposition il y
a pas eu le progrès démocratique pour
vous en Afrique centrale non en centrale
non en Afrique centrale non de temps en
temps en Afrique de l'Ouest il y a des
pays qui peuvent être cités comme des
exemples par exemple qu'est-ce que vous
je pense que jusqu'à une certaine mesure
où j'aurais préféré être du côté du
Sénégal que d'être du côté de ce
moi-même parce que moi par la suite on
avait un président qui était parti pour
aller l'Académie française bien sûr les
conditions de de l'arrivée de
Diouf c'était le premier ministre etc
mais ça s'était pas fait dans le sang et
puis il y a eu des élections et puis
Abdoulaye est parti nous sommes toujours
en Afrique centrale le la région dans
laquelle aucun président ne quitte le
pouvoir et peut se promener dans le
marché pour aller acheter je sais pas du
pain ou des arachides sont pour autant
que le peuple lui lance des pierres
alors justement c'est intéressant parce
qu'il y a les deux Congo et d'ailleurs
quand on est à Brazzaville on voit
Kinshasa pas loin et quand on est à
Kinshasa bah il y a le fleuve Congo il
fait 4 km ou 5 km de large ce qui est
intéressant c'est c'est de voir
l'évolution de ces deux pays les deux
Congo le Congo Brazzaville a eu une
période démocratique justement dans les
années 90 et ça sous une ghetto le
président Sassou-Nguesso était parti il
est revenu finalement il était parti
d'ailleurs crypto communiste à l'époque
et puis les revenus libéral en revanche
au Congo Kinshasa Mobutu ben il a été
chassé du pouvoir et bon bah il y a là
il y a pas la même évolution non il y a
pas la il y a pas la même évolution
disons le
mais même toi ils ont fait des élections
il y a les deux là quoi alors ça c'est
une question à gauche de l'écran et
Mobutu à droite en même temps du côté de
Mobutu c'est ce que après par la suite
il y a eu quand même de la période un
peu
nébuleuse de Kabila père et l'autre ils
ont eu des élections dans lesquelles le
président Tshisekedi qui est là et quand
même le fils d'Hélène des grands
opposants qui qui a été de Mobutu à
l'époque là donc dans une certaine
mesure moi je pense que le Congo
démocratique la RDC est en voie vers
peut-être un destin politique qui ne va
plus accepter qu'un dictateur puisse
squatter le pouvoir pendant 30 ans ils
ont déjà essayé une élection et je pense
que ça va aller dans ce sens le tout
c'est de rendre le peuple conscient de
la chance d'installer une démocratie
installer une démocratie de permettre
aux jeunes d'avoir une certaine
courtoisie politique de respecter celui
qui vous critique et tout comme de
célébrer celui qui dit quelque chose de
bien même s'il n'est pas de votre ethnie
même s'il n'est pas de votre région mais
en Afrique on a toujours ses
régionalisme comme au Congo Brazzaville
ou les gens vont dire que il y a d'un
côté les mauvais les nordistes et de
l'autre les bons les Sudistes c'est faux
les bons et les mauvais non pas de
géographie la bêtise et le bien peuvent
se changer de logement sans pour autant
qu'on se rende compte est-ce que vous
savez pourquoi la ville de Léopoldville
qui était anciennement Kinshasa était
débattisé alors que bah
Brazzaville c'est c'est savoir niant de
Brazza qui était un explorateur aussi on
a gardé le nom pourquoi mais parce que
dès lors que les
à l'époque au Congo belge de l'homme
qu'ils avaient eu leur indépendance il
s'était lancé dans une politique qu'on
appelait la politique de l'authenticité
la Zaïre réalisation d'accord cette
époque on est éliminé les traces les
traces vraiment de la colonisation très
dure en plus
c'était la propriété du roi Louis donc
il faisait donc à la nation au royaume
et donc par voie des conséquences
puisque on était dans une période de
temps ici donc on portait pas la cravate
on avait pas scottes
donc pas la cravate on n'avait pas de
prénom chrétiens etc mais le Congo d'en
face Brazzaville n'avait pas embrassé
cela le Congo avait plutôt embrassé
l'idéologie marxiste les ministres qui
est une idéologie somme toute
occidentales car le Marcelin il porte
des vestes donc si vous avez des cravate
donc ils avaient gardé l'ensemble et
puis il y avait aussi le fait que
Brazzaville se sentait comme toujours la
capitale de de la culture de l'Afrique
équatoriale française donc il y avait ce
prestige intellectuel or le prestige
intellectuel c'est par la langue
française que ça passe par les manières
occidentales à la maman cou si je vous
demande quel est votre écrivain préféré
ça serait lequel sur l'Afrique j'aime
beaucoup Camara Lay de la Guinée
parce que c'était l'un des premiers
écrivains qui au lieu de se lancer
forcément dans une certaine littérature
de combat ou quoi avait pensé d'écrire
la cellule familiale africaine j'étais
enfant je jouais j'aime les écrivains
qui parlent de leur enfance parce que
ils prennent leur singularité pour
l'exposer au monde comme un exemple de
la vie comment vous expliquer la France
a quand même un passé africain entre
guillemets que la littérature africaine
soit pas davantage d'enseignants en
France
c'est peut-être aussi
la crainte de ce qu'il y a dans la
marmite quand vous voulez manger quelque
chose peut-être que regarder peut-être
qu'il y aurait une nourriture allergique
à l'intérieur ils vont enseigner cahier
de retour au pays natal de mes Césaire
ou le discours sur la colonialisme il
avait fait mais on l'avait vite retiré
parce que certains textes de la
littérature africaine sont des des
explosifs qui sont cachés sont des
procès contre la colonisation j'ai dit
bateau là qu'on a montré tout à l'heure
le roman de René marron c'est la
critique aussi de la colonisation ville
cruelle de mungo Betty si la critique de
la colonisation les soleils des
indépendances c'est la crise des
Kourouma c'est la critique des mondes
anciens face au monde nouveau je veux
dire un livre comme le devoir de
violence du de du Malien Yambo
Games c'est aussi un mauvais visage pour
le pour les occidentaux donc je pense la
France n'est pas prête à vouloir se
faire de l'autoflagellation depuis les
bords des écoles où les jeunes petits
Français vont se rendre compte de la
vérité telle qu'elle était et alors donc
on tourne en rond on cherche toujours
des textes qui qui restent calme dans la
littérature classique française et ben
voilà vous vous avez écrit un livre qui
s'appelle le sanglot l'homme de l'homme
noir vous dites au noir aussi aux
Africains vous dites arrêtez de vous
plaindre sans arrêt aussi hein non je
veux dire que il faut pas non plus que
en soit sans cesse dans la situation de
l'Éternel victime c'est-à-dire que je ne
dois pas définir mon destin par rapport
à la dose de la victimisation qui me
caractérise à un moment donné je dois
conjuguer aussi mes verbes au présent
c'est pas toujours ce que vous
l'approchez ce livre on m'a reproché
quand il avait publié mais aujourd'hui
de plus en plus des gens viennent me
remercier parce que je dis des choses
qui se voient sur le terrain c'est ça
aussi la force d'un livre les livres les
plus critiqués au départ finissent par
avoir raison quand on arrive à la ligne
d'arrivée une musique une musique ben ça
serait toujours le grand orchestre de la
RDC OK Jazz de Franco encore voilà
Franco qui était un grand chanteur donc
de République démocratique du Congo à
l'époque c'était
mort malheureusement qui nous a quitté
qui est peut-être une des grandes forces
c'est la rumba congolaise dansé par les
sapeurs
et qui s'appelle mario c'est un de ses
principaux titres
[Musique]
nassina